I would not like to now analyze the
motion of a system of particles that has
both translational and rotational motion
so I'm going to consider a pulley and
the pulley has radius R and there is a
string wrapped around the pulley and a
block of object one that's on a plane
and another block of object 2 and as
object 2 falls down the pulley rotates
an object 1 moves to the right and
there's a coefficient of friction
between these block 1 and the surface
now in order to analyze this problem I'm
going to apply for the pulley our torque
equals ICM alpha and for each of the
blocks I'll apply f1 equals m1 a1
and f2 equals m2 a2 but the important
thing to realize is that these three
quantities the acceleration of block 1
the acceleration of block 2 and the
angular acceleration the pulley are
constrained because the string is not
slipping around the pulley and so let's
begin to analyze this type of problem so
we'll start with the torque principle
now what's crucial in all of these
problems is that we're relating two
different quantities vectors on both
sides the physics quantities have
definite direction and our alpha a1 and
a2 as vectors are determined by our
choice of coordinates so what I'd like
to do is draw a coordinate system a
rotational coordinate system now the way
I'll do it is I'll draw an angle theta
and now I have to draw a right-hand rule
so my angle theta will look as though
it's going into the plane of the figure
and so I right cross and hat right-hand
rule and I'm gonna just define that to
be K now what that allows me to do when
I write my point s here will be C
so I'm gonna calculate this about the
center of mass and I get ICM alpha as
soon as I draw the coordinate system
then this side becomes the vector alpha
Z K hat where alpha Z is the Z component
of the angular acceleration and
technically the reason this angle is
there is because this is the second
derivative of that angle and that's
well-defined now so the next step is to
define the force that do what we call a
torque diagram so this is my rotational
coordinate system the next step is to
construct a torque diagram in the way we
do that is we draw the object we
indicate our rotational coordinate
system I don't have to put the theta
anymore
now here's a subtle point I'm gonna draw
the rope that is connected to the pulley
as part of my system this is the part
where the tension here I'll call that t2
and over here this is the tension t1 now
on the pulley there is a gravitational
force and there's some pivot force on
this pulley and now what I want to
consider is the torque about the see it
now the pivot force of pivot and the
gravitational fork force produce no
torque about the pivot so I'm just gonna
eliminate those for the moment and just
focus on the torque due to t1 and t2 so
I draw my vector R s t1 and my vector R
st2 so this is what a torque diagram
consists of let's summarize it it's our
system the relevant forces that are
producing torque
vectors from the point where calculating
the torque RS is a little easier to
write S is the center of mass and the
vector from where we're calculating
torque to where the force is acting and
now when we calculate the cross product
of our s and T we put these two vectors
tail to tail and notice that this vector
is giving us a torque out of the board
our positive direction is into the board
so over here we have minus t1 R where is
t2 when we put these two vectors R as t2
and we calculate that torque that torque
is into the board which is our positive
direction and so that's plus t2 r2 and
now in our torque principle we set these
two sides equal and we have minus t1 r
plus t2 R equals ICM alpha Z now this is
our first equation but it requires some
type of thought for the first thing we
see that the tension t2 is equal to IC M
over R alpha Z plus t1 so the tensions
on the side are not equal now when we
studied pulleys earlier in the semester
we imposed a condition that the pulley
was frictionless which meant that the
rope was sliding along the pulley and
there was no rotation in the pulley so
there was no contribution to alpha and
in that case t2 would be equal to t1 we
also could make a slightly different
statement we could say suppose the mass
of the pulley were very very small in
extremely light pulley then ICM would be
0 and again t2 would be equal to t1 so
when we were dealing with either
massless pulleys or ropes that were
slipping frictionlessly along a pulley
the tension on both sides was equal now
something different is happening we need
to apply a greater torque here than t1
you know because there is rotational
inertia
we're causing the pulley to accelerate
so this the torque from t2 has to be
bigger than the torque from T 1 and
therefore t 2 is bigger than T 1 so that
is a very important way to apply the
torque principle when T 2 is bigger than
T 1 alpha will be positive and a
positive angular acceleration is giving
a rotation in which our angle theta is
not only increasing but its second
derivative is positive so that's crucial
for beginning the analysis of this
problem the next step is to analyze
Newton's second law on both objects M 1
and M 2 so I'll save our result here
I'll erase what we don't need and then
continue the analysis so returning to
our analysis of a pulley with two masses
and a string that's not slipping around
the pulley I now want to begin analysis
of F equals MA on object 1 so as usual I
draw object 1 I'll choose I have 1/2
point in the direction because I know
it's going to go that way so my
component acceleration will be positive
and my force diagrams I have a normal
force
I have gravity the string is pulling t 1
that's the same tension at the end of
the string the tension in the string is
not changing we're assuming it's a
massless string and I have a friction
force on object 1 just kinetic friction
and now I can write down Newton's second
law in the horizontal direction I could
also call J hat 1 up and my two
equations for Newton's second law is T 1
minus FK is m1 a1 and n1 minus m1 G is 0
now I also know that the kinetic
friction FK is the coefficient of
friction mu times N 1 so my next
equation for F equals MA on object T 1
is T 1 minus mu N 1
equals m1 a1 now I have to apply the
same analysis to to notice I'm not
drawing my force diagram on my sketch I
do a separate force diagram on to so
here's two I have tension t2 and gravity
and 2g now even though I chose a unit
vector up here this choice of unit
vectors is completely independent of how
I choose unit vectors for - because
object is moving down I would prefer to
choose J hat - down my acceleration for
this object will be positive and then
when I apply F equals MA - object - I
get m2 G minus t2 equals m2 a2 so that's
now my third equation that m2 G minus t2
equals m2 a2 and now I look at this
system of equations and I have what are
my unknowns t1 t2 alpha a 1 a 2 5
unknowns I'm treating properties of the
system the radius mu ICM actually the
and one because it's m1 G I can simplify
this equation and replace this with m1 G
where I'm already using the other
Newton's second law so I have five
equations I have three equations in five
unknowns I cannot solve this system but
in all of these problems there is
constraint conditions
there's constraints between how the
masses are moving and how the angular
acceleration of pulley is related to the
linear acceleration in the masses let's
consider mass 1 and 2 they're attached
by a string as mass 2 goes down mass 1
goes to the right the string is not
stretching so they're moving at the same
rate so they have its same acceleration
so my first constraint
is that a1 equals a2 now in general I
have to be careful plus or minus why is
it a plus sign and not a minus sign here
it's a plus sign because I've chosen I
hat to the right and I chosen J hat to
downwards if I chosen them differently
that sign could have varied now let's
focus on the relationship between the
angular acceleration of the pulley and
m2 think about the string here we're on
a point on the rim this is a distance R
and the string the pulley and the string
are moving together so there's a
tangential acceleration of the pulley
equal to R alpha Z this is the
tangential acceleration of pulley and
string but the same string has a linear
acceleration either a 1 or a 2 so this
has to be equal to a 2 this is the
linear acceleration of the string and so
that's our last constraint v that a 1
equals R alpha and now I have a system
of five equations and 5 unknowns
and the question is is how can I find
the acceleration so in general when
opposed to a system like that I want to
have some strategy let's make a little
space to clear for our algebra ok now
I look at this system and I say to
myself which equation do I want to use
as a background my target is to find a1
a1 is equal to a2 now
when I look at these equations t1
depends on a 1 t2 depends on a 2 which
is equal to a-1 and alpha is also
related to a 1 so I can use this
equation 1 as my backbone and substitute
in T 1 T 2 and alpha into that equation
and now let's do that so when I solve
this equation for T 1 equal to m1 a1
plus mu M 1 G with a minus sign I get
minus m1 a1 plus mu M 1 G times R it's
my first piece I solve for t2 which is
m2 G minus m2 a so I get m2 G minus m2
now a2 is equal to a-1 so I make my
second substitution x R and that's equal
to IC m and now I make my final
substitution that alpha Z is equal to a
1 over R so if I now can collect terms
minus minus over here but there's an R
there and are there I'll divide through
by r and bring my a 1 terms over to the
other side and I'm left with minus mu
and 1 g plus m2 G equals I see M over R
squared that has the dimensions of mass
because moment of inertia M R squared
divided by R squared plus M 1 a 1 plus M
2 A 1 and finally as a conclusion I now
can solve for the acceleration of my
system in terms of all of these
quantities and let's just put it all the
way down here at the bottom that a1
equals m2 G
- Mew m1g / ICM R squared plus m1 plus
m2 often in types of problems like these
when there's a lot of sign errors you
might end up with a minus or minus sign
down here and if you looked at that that
would imply that with the right choice
of parameters this could be 0 and that
would be an impossible solution so it's
always a sign that there could be
something wrong the other thing we want
to check is when does it actually
accelerate we have a condition
so Inc we can conclude that if m2 G is
bigger than you and 1 G then 2 will
start to go downwards if m2 G were less
than and 1 G then the problem would be
very different because 2 would not go
downwards the friction would not be
kinetic but would be static and that
would vary depending on how much weight
we're here so if you went from zero to
mu + 1 G the static friction would
depend on how much weight that's there
so here is a full analysis of rotational
and translational motion takes a little
bit of time and a little bit of care but
we've done it